of drawing all you need to do is
eliminate white's pawn because rook
versus knight is a draw so even if black
loses all his pawns if you eliminate
white's pawns to draw but
is that more okay so here i'm just
thinking take the pawn
take the pawn what yeah for white takes
porn
is okay maybe that was super risky
though taking over okay there would have
been a night check in the night and
they're not dropping down yeah so okay
magnus just decides get rid of black's
best pawn
and uh okay now we see that pawn
disappear black knight has to move and
this game is fizzling towards a draw we
might see rook versus knight play out on
the board without any pawns but if the
knight if uh the player with the knight
knows how to defend it should be a draw
yeah
and both players you can tell on their
body language they know it should be a
draw and
there we go
magnus doesn't even try and win he gives
up his broken a knight alone cannot give
checkmate
all right magnus carlsen he is breathing
a sigh of relief a tough game here
against shakriyad mama